So,
I did my training uh.
The week of the 14th
and uh.
We took everything that is safe,
security,
uh.
Since also well
there are workouts for,
uh. Your uh.
Your interviews.
We went to the airport,
we did simulations
and you go to the airport,
finally,
1 time you are going to put your foot in it
with uh. Yes,
you will really understand the context.
And it was great.
So, well,
I applied on Friday,
I was called yesterday and then,
well I'm taken today.
That's it,
that's very good.
Good luck.
Do you have any questions?
No, sorry, no, no,
she is waiting for her badge.
They will apply for my badge directly
because it takes a little time.
Request a badge,
so they will trigger it.